go back a hundred no no no 120 years 120
years ago you want to do adding and
subtracting well you'll do long adding
and subtracting if you were really
clever and you're really rich you would
have a French Aerith ometer but if you
really wanted to do a lot of arithmetic
you're kind of stuck Hans
eglee 1894 1895 in Switzerland came up
with an absolutely wonderful device a
calculator called the millionaire it'll
not only add it'll multiply and divide
it'll even subtract so it's a four
function calculator it has handles on
either side I can lift this up just and
it only weighs 60 or 70 pounds a
portable calculator smaller than a piano
you can't get cooler than that let's try
to just add three crank this around once
grip three once this three again three
plus three is six again nine and then 12
15 18 21 okay so every time I want to
add a number I crank this around once I
crank it around once every time I want
it add let's try something slightly more
complex let's set this to 14 million six
hundred five three one so this is 14
million six hundred thirty seven
thousand five hundred thirty one okay
I'll add this once okay
the answer is fourteen million six
hundred thirty-seven 531 again
this number plus itself twenty-nine
million two hundred seventy five below
hook again so each time I add this I've
now multiplied this by three fourteen
million six hundred thirty seven five
three one times three is forty three
million nine hundred twelve thousand
five hundred ninety three not bad it
adds and by successive addition I can
just crank around and one more time and
again and go oh yeah yeah big deal
the cool thing the absolute wonderful
thing about the millionaire machine is
it has one crank multiplication I can
multiply a big number by a single digit
in one turn let's do a reset
I'll set to multiply so I'll multiply
this big number instead of by one I'll
multiply it by seven seven times this
number will wind up down here
crank it around one time one single
crank this big number fourteen million
six hundred thirty seven thousand times
seven is 102 million four hundred
sixty-two thousand seven hundred
seventeen but watch this instead of
multiplying by seven let's multiply by
74 one turn one turn
now let's multiply let's make this this
big number times 749 we should pick up a
nine over here one turn 14 million
blahblahblah times 749 is 10 billion
nine hundred sixty three million five
hundred ten thousand and seven hundred
nineteen so we're already into the
billions and let's multiply once more by
six single turn fourteen million six
hundred thirty seven thousand five
hundred thirty one times seven thousand
four hundred ninety six is 100 in nine
billion seven hundred twenty two million
nine hundred thirty two thousand three
hundred and seventy six all that
multiplying required just four turns of
this because this millionaire has built
into it a read-only memory that knows
the multiply tables it knows that 7
times 2 is 14 this thing knows that 1
times 7 is 7
it knows that eight times four is a 32
brady could i take them upstairs Brady
says it's ok for me to show you the
read-only memory come over here okay
guys I actually have two of these this
one I'm repairing boy there's a lot to
fix inside of it this is the multiply
unit all milled by hand out of brass
along here is the read-only memory is
the multiply table put in brass it'll
multiply any one digit essentially it
knows that 0 times anything is 0 it
knows that 1 times anything is itself
all the way up to 9 it knows it's tables
from 0 to 9 it knows the ninth table
here's the zero table
one two three four five all the way up
to nine so maybe I can show this by
bringing this over here and turning this
you'll see these levers engage with the
table right now if I want to multiply by
zero you'll notice nothing engages with
this multiplying by one a multiply by
two
let's multiply by nine crank this all
the way over here and the bottom row of
fingers will push along here in register
nine times each of these digits to bring
them down into the results table
absolutely amazing I'm blown away in
Switzerland a hundred twenty years ago
people had the smarts to figure out how
to build the predecessor to today's
computers I got two of them about 35
years ago thirty-eight years ago in
Buffalo New York a bank was closing up I
was at the auction I paid a good penny
for this it was considered to be worth
its weight in brass yep I paid $75 for
it which was about how much the brass
was worth I made it even more portable
by mounting it on wheels so that I can I
can close it up and take it wherever I
wish next time I need to multiply add
subtract or divide I know just how to go
to
what now the cost of this is the
chiropractic bills of carrying it
whatever it's worth on eBay would be
subtracted by the shipping costs of
something that weighs 50 75 100 pounds